what's happening my name's samuel leeds
i've got really bad news for you on this
video and i've also got really good news
on this video so i would really badly
suggest that you watch the video until
the end because the good news is very
good and i've got a gift for you today
okay so number one
bad news
2022
i believe is going to be a very
challenging tough hard year we went into
lockdown in 2020
we were told it would be three weeks
it's now almost two years later now
we're about to enter 2022 and there is
talk of more lockdowns coming to this
country in england
across in wales and scotland there are
very very tough restrictions there's
many countries across the planet which
are in full lockdown and i've just got
back from dubai i'm in the uk i've been
speaking to a lot of very very high up
well well researched learned people who
think that 2022 is going to be another
very very challenging year so that's the
bad news how's that going to affect you
well for a start we know what happens
when there are
lockdowns and restrictions and
challenging times with the pandemic what
happens is that a lot of companies go
bust there is
massive massive redundancies and also an
overwhelming amount of uncertainty which
means that people have mental health
issues that means people either are
losing their jobs or are fearful that
they might lose their jobs so that's the
bad news and i don't see this problem
going away anytime soon i remember when
last year we went into 2021 and we were
thinking let's leave all this virus
stuff behind us and move into a new year
and what happened we still had a year of
restrictions and fear and redundancies
and recession and i think the same thing
is going to happen again as we move into
2022
people are just hoping and praying and
crossing their fingers that everything's
going to blow over and this is going to
be you know a problem of the past and
2022 is going to be all new and will
probably be disappointed so that's the
bad news what is the good news well the
good news is that throughout the
pandemic and the
lockdowns there were more people
becoming millionaires than i've ever
seen before in my lifetime and i have
just released a whole new book now this
book
is a thick book not a slim book it's a
thick book
it's got 30 chapters in it and every
chapter is dedicated to one of my
success students now this was written
through the lockdown
this book is about stories from people
throughout the lockdown who've becoming
financially free and property
millionaires
through the pandemic so what's the good
news the good news is that you can
become financially free even through
these restrictions i mean with these
stories we've got people like lawton
hopwood lawton hopwood did his financial
freedom challenge when
in a lockdown
when did when did um
when did these guys look we've got like
um andrett who's completely financially
free when did me and energy work
together it was drawing a lockdown where
everything was closed
these stories are all stories about
people there's 30 of them
that have become financially free or
absolutely killed it in their property
business
through
lockdown let me tell you something
everything has changed the rules have
changed if you read my first success
students book which was volume one
it was completely different the stories
the strategies the techniques were
completely different to volume two so
this is the good news the good news is
number one that you can
succeed in property like never before
during
redundancies lockdowns restrictions fear
recession you can
win big time in property the second
thing is as it's just after christmas
and we're going into a new year as a
happy new year gift i wanted to give you
a copy of this book
it's a big thick book and uh i think
you're gonna
really enjoy reading it
evans willie's in there some of these
guys are famous as well like we got my
man right beaumont he he's part of a boy
band very very very very successful also
got my friend crept crep the rapper
we've got rugby players football players
kevin stewart former player for
liverpool so there's people through the
pandemic that were my students that will
becoming successful by investing
strategically in property to property
development by refurbishing finance
through the pandemic and we're doing it
well and
up today they're in here also the
stories of people that were literally
almost homeless and got started out and
became successful we've got people um
that were very young as well like my man
here um ali ali came to me he was 19 20
years old now he's done dozens of deals
um we've got people like david taylor
who came to me he'd been in construction
in property for a long time transitioned
into his own property investment
business he's now he owns a castle
he owns like so many pieces of land he's
building houses from scratch so this is
the newest book on property investment
that you can read and you can be
inspired by and see what people are
doing today not a couple years or a few
years ago today and i want to give you a
free copy of this so how am i going to
do that well there is very this is going
to be for a very limited amount of time
but i'm going to leave an amazon link in
the description and you can get the
kindle version even if you don't own a
kindle you can get it on your iphone or
computer or any device you can get the
kindle version and you can get it now
for free and it will sit on your phone
on your computer on your kindle forever
and ever and ever you can keep it
forever and it is completely free as a
gift from me to you but make sure you do
it right now because this amazon are
only going to be able to they only let
me give away things for free on amazon
for a certain um a very short amount of
days so do it now
get your copy be inspired and learn how
these people have made money in property
through the pandemic and how you can too
going into 2022.
thanks so much i'll leave a link in the
description and i'll see you soon happy
new year